sa vie la stratégie de dormans 30 qui
vise a accusé les médias de fausses
nouvelles à son égard est en fait très
peu protégés une politique
[Musique]
en effet en 1675 le roi d'angleterre
charles 2éme et une proclamation royale
qui va faire scandale
en effet une vient d'interdire aux gens
d'aller dans les maisons de café et les
maisons de thé partout sur le territoire
de l'angleterre
alors qu'à l'époque ce sont des lieux
qui sont terriblement populaire nous
sommes à l'époque de la restauration
charles ii est remonté sur le trône
alors que son père avait été exécuté en
il est très inquiet pour sa réputation
et celle de son gouvernement
c'est une époque où le roi doit
travailler avec un gouvernement et des
députés élus et la population sans
qu'elle doit s'informer de la politique
et ce sont dans les maisons de café que
la plupart des gens vont écouter leur
fait différente bilbocks concerne la
gestion de l'état craignant qu'il y ait
beaucoup trop de fausses rumeurs à son
égard et qu'il y ait beaucoup trop de
ragots concernant son gouvernement et sa
gestion de l'état charles 2 et met donc
en 1675 cette proclamation qui vise à
interdire de la fréquentation des
maisons de thé des maisons de café afin
que les fausses rumeurs cessent est-ce
que cela a fonctionné
pas vraiment en fait la plupart des
propriétaires de maison du café ont peur
de la fermeture de leur établissement et
sont allés voir directement le roi afin
de demander une dérogation charles doit
accepter en disant qu'il devait payer
500 livres pour garder leur
établissement ouvert il devait surtout
prêter allégeance au roi non seulement
en tant que personne et aussi pour
d'autres la clientèle qu'elle ait
fréquenté leur maison café est ce que la
population a cessé de fréquenter les
maisons de café certainement pas jadis
pour déroger un ordre royal et jean rey
perdu la tête
mais à l'époque de charles 2 puisque on
entre dans une ère un peu plus
républicaine où la politique est
démocratisé les gens passent et autres
la proclamation royale
[Musique]